through the first 10 games compared to
maybe last year his best season overall
how does he look this year's Derrick
Rose it's a thrill well to me can be
better defensive played 30 games and did
not speak out through law passes dimes
down the lane he won the Wooden Award we
didn't see it impacted us no question
about it and I love him today rose line
drive that's a two-pointer he's got he's
got 12 also unstoppable down low as
Rhodes launches gets Derrick Rose for 5
from that distance when he was healthy
and whole legendary workouts in Santa
Monica California of Ingram now this guy
here Wiggins has been very quiet 2nd
half what do you having first half 17
Rose hits another three another three
for Derrick Rose the largest lead of the
game for the Lakers James harassing
Wiggins
roast reporter got it Tara queer novels
least 6 of 7 from downtown and it's back
to 4
[Applause]
roll steps back again Roxanne and
Patrick Rose makes it a one-point game
at the back threes pushed the Wolves
back in this ball game tough shots